you know the big thing for for me
personally the was for this to have its
own voice and for it to sound like what
does deadmau5 sound like the orchestral
version
[Music]
what's gonna sound the best with his
games what's gonna translate all those
were the questions before even even
getting to that to that point and then
it was trying to keep it lean trying to
keep it modern and trying to keep you
know that that was the thing for it to
have its own voice and and not to be
compared to something else so after that
was a dialogue between us and he was
very adamant and I was really glad about
that too you know which is something
even more risky he didn't want any
percussion he didn't want you know once
you strip that away you're making the
music more vulnerable you're exposing
more so you have to it has to be even
more perfect I really didn't have much
of a choice
it'll be honest to kind of hand the
reins to him on a lot of my projects
because I am NOT of that world and I
don't know the process evolved and you
know the kind of stylistic touches that
he'd have to do with it to make it of
that world you know I can I can emulate
Orchestra stuff you know I've got
contact and you know string libraries
and stuff so yeah sure but I don't know
the the sonic possibilities in the and
then the way that that transcribed to
real players and stuff like that
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna be up there with like you know
60 world class you know musicians so all
doing that thing respectively with a
conductor who's been conducting longer
than I've been alive you know and it's
all you know premium proper and then I'm
like am I gonna do I like I know I'll
bring my boat
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you